former vice president Mike Pence a
horrible vice president is going to be
testifying about conversations he had
with Donald Trump leading up to January
6th a judge has ruled Pence can't get
out of it he's going to have to testify
this could be absolutely explosive
because one of the things we have
learned is that Donald Trump was urging
Mike Pence reject the ballots reject the
electors rejects somehow figure out a
way to prevent Joe Biden from becoming
president during the certification of
the 2020 election and Mike Pence said no
I'm not going to do it and I can't do it
constitutionally we may learn we may
learn
what those conversations were except and
this is where I don't want people to get
their hopes up except
Mike Pence has to show up to answer
questions but individually he can
decline to answer questions so it's
still possible that Pence will show up
he'll be sworn in and he will decline to
answer any particular question